today i'm putting together a fantastic
breakfast lunch and dinner with an
american flavor
i've traveled throughout the united
states for my work and as well as having
some shockingly bad meals over there
i've also had some brilliant ones
and right now the u.s food scene is
really vibrant
lots of new talented young chefs
incorporating new flavors into their
dishes
and reinventing american classics taking
my cue from some of the best
this is my ultimate american home
cooking
first up for breakfast my take on a us
diner classic
eggs baked with crispy hash browns and
smoky sweet bacon
for lunch the mighty american caesar
salad with griddle chicken breast
and a big bold dressing followed by
peanut butter and jam cookies to die for
time for a little drink and middle
daughter holly
joins me in the kitchen you put yours in
there i'll put mine here
dad we're creating an american feast
with barbecue style beef brisket
crunchy like coleslaw and spicy sweet
potato wedges
this is my ultimate american food
breakfast
lunch and dinner first up eggs bait in
hash browns
the secret of a great hash brown are the
potatoes
i prefer using really nice waxy potatoes
they cook better but more importantly
hold themselves together
we're not gonna slice the onion all the
potatoes but we're actually gonna grate
them
the potatoes get really nice and crispy
i mean seriously crispy
now the onion
that way you get that nice balance of
the onion flavor running through
every little shard of potato
[Music]
season with salt pepper olive oil and km
give that a really good mix through
and then squeeze all that water out
and look at all that juice we squeeze
out there really important
the more liquid you remove the crispier
your hash browns will be
nice large pan put that on once the
pan's hot
pour in a good glug of olive oil
[Music]
that sound confirms how important it is
to have your pan
nice and hot so it seals
the grated potato and onion together so
take the spoon
and just pat it down what we're trying
to do now is get it really nice and
compact
going around the outside of the pan with
little flecks of butter
you just slip them down the back gently
and that gets the onions caramelised
here's a great tip for turning your hash
browns over
quick and easy take a plate
place it on top and just
flip it over and then slide it back in
very quickly you see the color
we've got on there now got that nice
crispy texture of the potato
i'm going to use the hash brown as a bed
for my baked eggs
crack in your eggs nice and gently just
a little sprinkling
of the cayenne to make the eggs a little
bit spicy
then into a preheated oven for six to
eight minutes
meanwhile onto my bacon and i'm giving
it a classic american twist
now one thing i could never get my head
around when i first started eating lots
of american breakfast was the sweetness
from the bacon
i've grown up to love that combination
of smoky sweet flavors
and it's so easy pan on and simply heat
olive oil
brown sugar salt and pepper and butter
bacon in and as it cooks it becomes
irresistibly caramelized and golden
brown
top of gas and my glazed bacon
absolutely ready beautiful now my hash
browns and baked eggs are ready
wow look at that
beautiful just put your spatula
underneath there
onto your plate and that bacon sets
beauty on top of the baked eggs and that
hash brown underneath and
you can see why the best breakfasts in
the world
are always in america
this is an all-american superhero offer
breakfast
eggs bait in hash browns with glazed
bacon
[Music]
next i'm showing you a fantastic
american inspired lunch and dinner
[Music]
but you don't need to go to the us to
buy the ingredients here's a closer look
at the key ones
first up it's beef brisket a super cheap
cut from the breast of the cow
it's underused in the uk but loved by
american cousins
and used for incredible delicates like
pastrami and succulent salt beef
the key to beef brisket is to cook it
low and slow
to make it tender and i've got a
delicious bbq style recipe for dinner
[Music]
next sweet potatoes as american as apple
pie
sometimes called yams in the usa they're
native to the tropical americans
they cook quicker than standard potatoes
they're packed with nutrients
and have a fantastic sweet flavor
whether you mash them
bake them or roast them but i really
love the simple sweet potato wedges
i'm making for dinner
[Music]
the ultimate american staple has to be
peanut butter
and more than half the peanuts grown in
the u.s are used to make it
i love it both crunchy or smooth and not
just spread on bread
it's fantastic in savory sauces like
satay or even in desserts
like the peanut butter and jam cookies
i'm making for lunch
the main course will be a crispy big
caesar salad
but the first job are my peanut butter
and jam cookies
[Music]
start with a cookie dough simply combine
muscovado sugar
peanut butter and butter until light and
fluffy
then add your egg a splash of milk
vanilla seeds
and beat again until smooth
sift together salt baking powder and
flour
and mix until thoroughly combined
floured hands roll the cookie dough into
golf ball sizes
flatten and create an indent with your
finger
fill with half jam and half peanut
butter
place the cookies on a tray lined with
baking paper and bake in a preheated
oven for 10 to 12 minutes
cool before serving
[Music]
next job main course and my take on an
iconic
american salad first made almost a
century ago
caesar salad is definitely a classic
but the trick to keeping dishes like
this modern and relevant
is to tweak them but not lose what made
them brilliant
in the first place here's my version for
the ultimate american lunch
my first twist is in the dressing for me
the most important part of the caesar
salad
is that dressing rich creamy
slightly spicy begin by making a basic
mayonnaise
start off with the egg yolks in just
a little spoon dijon and then a little
splash
of red wine vinegar start whisking
once you've got that nice slightly
thickened texture
drizzling your olive oil
it should fall through your whisk
it's like a nice thick double cream
texture
beautiful now take the mayo to another
level with anchovies
and crushed garlic now chop up
the anchovies and the garlic together so
we almost want that to be like a really
nice
puree then grated parmesan lemon juice
that will make the dressing
citrusy lighter in color
and then a little splash of water in
now all of a sudden it transforms that
mayonnaise
into an amazing delicious
light dressing nice
next job the croutons and i like using
crusty bread for extra crunch
and just dice up your bread season with
salt and pepper then
add to a hot pan with olive oil and fry
give that a really nice toss as the
croutons start to turn golden
simply grate on a generous amount of
parmesan cheese keep them rolling around
stop them from sticking together look at
that really nice cheesy
delicious crouton and now
they're out now for the fun job
assembling the caesar salad starting
with romaine lettuce
and don't slice the lettuce
too thinly a squeeze of lemon on with
half of that gutsy
anchovy mayo dressing saving some to
coat your chicken later
then sprinkle half your croutons give
that
a really nice mix salad in
it's all beautifully dressed add the
remaining croutons
and finish with a good grating of
parmesan cheese
that for me is a perfect caesar salad
however
i'm gonna take it to another level and
grill a stunning
chicken breast start by preheating your
griddle pan
then butterfly your chicken breast
simply slice from the thin end towards
the thick bit
of the breast let the knife do the work
and literally just
open up now that's how we butterfly
a chicken breast so therefore it will
cook twice as quick
and just nice and moist in the center
season the chicken on both sides with
salt and ground pepper
lay your chicken breast onto the grill
[Music]
never oil the grill until absolutely
ready to cook your chicken
now turn them over
[Music]
beautiful cook for three to four minutes
on each side until the chicken's got
those lovely stripes from the griddle
which adds a gorgeous smoky flavor
whilst they rest spoon over some of the
remaining anchovy dressing
the chicken cools down the flavour the
seasoning of the anchovy
the garlic and the palm zone seeps into
that chicken slice the chicken
into strips
wow i serve the chicken warm in a
separate bowl
so it doesn't wilt the salad just bring
the dressing
finish that with a little touch of
dressing
an american classic i think one of the
most popular salads anywhere in the
world
but it's still one of the most delicious
when it comes to lunch this really is an
american dream
a delicious caesar salad and succulent
golden griddle chicken
with peanut butter and jam cookies for
dessert
when it comes to cooking techniques
barbecue is virtually a religion in
america
especially in the southern states down
there the real barbecue pros use big
open fire pits
to get huge joints of meat super
succulent and fantastically perfume
with smoke and spice so my ultimate
american dinner
has to include an amazing mouth in the
mouth barbecue beef
but i'm doing it the easy way cooked in
the oven low
and slow my family has spent a lot of
time in the u.s and they love american
food joining me in the kitchen today is
jack's twin sister
holly we're creating bbq style beef
brisket
with crunchy coleslaw and sweet potato
wedges which will be right up her street
holly now
you love barbecues right so gonna help
me barbecue this delicious
piece of brisket brisket look at it
beautiful it's a very tough cut of meat
so it needs to be cooked slowly
so it gets really nice and tender are we
barbecuing it outside
we're gonna actually put the barbecue
flavor on there but we're gonna cook it
in the oven
okay so mustard powder okay
here we have some celery seed next
a little bit of salt in there okay
what's this here
cumin two again
nice good now this one
cayenne pepper absolutely right right
two teaspoons of that in there as well
good now what i want you to do
fresh pepper on there i'll give that a
little mix
roll up your little sleeves and then i
want you
to rub all that spice
into the brisket almost like you're
massaging it in there
good girl come on holes get your hands
nice and flat on there
good girl now that's nice and coated
okay in the spice so
gas on roasting tray on what we've got
to do now
with all those spices is sear them in a
couple of tablespoons of olive oil
into the tray
well done good that's getting nice and
hot now you get your brisket
and all that spice lay that in there
nicely
okay so now we'll start coloring it
as you start to sear in you smell those
spices
yep all that spice left on the plate
we're gonna use yeah i want you to get
the onions
nice and carefully slice them down not
too thin
but just like you're chopping them take
your time
smell all those spices now
good girl thank you don't wash my hands
i can rub my eyes
damn holly was homework that bad
no the onions oh no don't rub your eyes
don't rub your eyes
[Music]
we've got the colour look on the brisket
okay yeah take that out literally for 30
seconds
okay onions into the tray please
nice you see it's starting to smell
slightly barbecuey already
give that a little stir
nice now one nice tablespoon
of brown sugar what does the brown sugar
do dad so the brown sugar
you're gonna start caramelizing the
onions right from there
my bay leaves in please good girl oh
yes please right do we'll take over
good care of that tray is very very hot
a tablespoon
of tomato puree roast that off at the
bottom of the tray
and really rub it in amongst the onions
good girl
now look at the colors onions right now
time for a little drink
for the brisket
okay one bottle of beer in please so you
go in you put yours in there i'll put
mine here
god uh good health to you and your
brisket good health
bring that to the ball okay now this is
where it gets really exciting
i want you to lift the brisket up and
put it on top of the onions in she goes
good girl and then i want you to pour
the stock all the way around please
i'm using beef stock but it will work
with chicken stock or even vegetable
stock
once the stock has come to the boil
cover tightly with foil
you just pinch in the ends
flatten that down and then you just
twist all the way
so that's nice and tight that's the hard
work done thank you
simply pop it in the oven for three and
a half hours and as it cooks you can get
on with the side dishes
first job sweet potato wedges with some
serious flavor
start by making a spice mix in a dry pan
toast coriander seeds until beautifully
aromatic
then put them in a pestle and mortar add
salt and grind
[Music]
next smoked paprika dried oregano
cayenne pepper and mix spice mix done
now simply cut your sweet potatoes into
wedges
toss in olive oil and thoroughly cover
with the spice mix
onto a baking tray and into a preheated
oven for 30 minutes
turning halfway irresistible sweet
potato wedgies are ready
now to finish off my beef
see that smell just sort of travels
everywhere
oh ah now look at that
so we can leave that to rest what does
resting mean resting means where
you've cooked a joint and you just leave
it to relax so it'll make the meat so
much more tender
okay right coleslaw traditionally you
would mix
slaw with what mayonnaise that's right
mayonnaise
this time we're gonna do it a little
different so i'd like you to put the
yogurt into the bowl for me
please all of it i'll start slicing the
white cabbage
and the red cabbage now from there a
nice tablespoon
of mustard in there please give that a
nice mix up
nice little touch of salt and pepper
okay now a little cider vinegar
so a little splash of cider vinegar in
there
okay as i shred this okay i'd like you
please then to get the red cabbage
and just open up into that and mix in at
the same time
and then you fold that in there as i
start shredding
see how it's coming together yeah
right that's all the red cabbage now the
white
so you've got that nice vinegary
tartness to the slaw and the yogurt
keeps it nice and fresh
last little bit in one more little thing
so put some nice
chopped fresh chives in there and that
will give it this nice
light onion flavor
so shines in
how's that now taste it with the chives
in there
um delicious so
i would like you to fill up the bowl i'm
gonna very carefully lift out
my brisket how come is it shrunk it's
been in the oven
for nearly three and a half hours so
it's been cooked slowly
that sits on there oh my goodness me let
me just show you what this looks like
i'll start slicing it and see how soft
look at that and here's the thing about
helping daddy cook
here's the perk you get to taste it
first
before anybody that is so good that
tastes delicious see all that wonderful
flavor
in there last job is to create an
incredibly quick and delicious sauce
gas on and reduce the spicy juices and
onions the beef cooked in
then add in cider vinegar and you've got
a brilliant tangy barbecue sauce
that smells nice doesn't it
wow that is brisket
and a half now the rest of it can go in
the gravy pot
that's a really nice rich
spicy barbecue
onion gravy
that my daddy is the perfect way
to serve brisket right you ready if you
carry
the sweet potato for me i've got the
brisket wow
let's go donny well done by the way
thank you
this is a real american beauty gorgeous
low and slow cooked barbecue beef
brisket with sweet potato wedges and
yogurt coleslaw
megan jack tilly big deep smoky flavors
that bring the taste of the american
south to your kitchen
who would like some coleslaw and who
would like some gravy thank you
spicy and slightly barbecue how's the
brisket really good
it's amazing especially with the gravy
and what do you think of the capability
of your big sister
i think she did this one pretty good you
think so
maybe not as good as mine but i can
feel a lot of competition
in amongst the ramsey girls good job
thank you
there are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app
cook with me you can find it in the app
store good luck
you